the mainstream narrative around the
Chinese spy balloon makes no sense see
while China says it was just a harmless
weather balloon that drifted off course
the U.S claims that those spy balloons
are part of a large surveillance
operation with at least two dozen
missions over five continents in recent
years but this doesn't make sense China
has much more powerful ways to spy on
its enemies Like high-res Satellites and
drones why would they need a giant
balloon the size of three buses to
collect information it makes no sense
maybe they sent this balloon on purpose
to see how the US government would react
after they finally shot it down the
Chinese government said it was an
overreaction in that they will retaliate
in the future or maybe the US is using
this as a distraction a way to fuel
people's fears and hatred against China
you know to justify the next War click
the link in the pinned comment to learn
how the world really works because